[Music]
and another one bites the dust another
one bites the dust baby another one
submitted by Mary me Joe Queen well I
don't know you okay after being bit by a
venomous snake ocean and his wife
because he wanted them to die together
that's the stupidest [ __ ] I've ever
heard doubtful things thinks are zombies
or what hold up I have a question from a
guy's perspective I'm like this
[ __ ] selfish but I know how
girls are and you guys are probably what
a romantic [ __ ] huh you probably
the same [ __ ] like who would die
together oh yeah yeah stupid yeah oh so
now you became like a [ __ ] snake
vampire and now you have this serum that
you could pass to the rest of us you're
dumb but you crave like that romantic
stuff how romantic
that's complimented how come girls like
Twilight there and [ __ ] that guy's
like biting her and like are you talking
about nine-year-old girls oh you can't
do it Twilight such a dumb [ __ ] me
well that's the difference between guys
and girls
nine-year-old boys think exactly the
same as a 30 year old boy yeah I'll ban
diggin I'm glad you're proud of that no
that's because we know what we want we
don't like and change it to snakes I
hate snakes I think they're they are
describing this was a [ __ ] dumbass
dude he's like I've been infected yeah
now he's here that must've hurt
I know biting combining his girlfriend
issues can you imagine
he got bit and she's like trying to help
him with his wound and the first thing
he does is [ __ ] bite his girlfriend
in the arm what he should have said is
just suck the venom then don't fight her
do [ __ ] by the way a terrible terrible
time I mean if you wanted them to die
together and she drinks it yeah was she
was she okay with this okay so first of
all it takes place in India I knew it
how do you know I'm scared because
they're romantic okay I just like the
idea that this guy just dude thinks that
he has venom coming out of teeth being
healthy but funny because I pictured a
guy with leather sandals on trying to
fight
all right now you know it's funny that's
not true though right um look you know
the one that I got a looper in the
[ __ ] big toaster right when I hear
Indy I picture that and I picture the
most ashy of speed on earth yeah Angela
yeah black with a white light right sure
it's been fresh yeah you see nipples and
everything they probably have a mustache
yep nice thick one gold necklace yeah
you old um up so this man um do you
think that I'm a snake I can be sound
like Vietnamese all right so what's
being reported is that when this man was
sleeping he was bit bitten by a venomous
snakes I don't know what kind of snake
is reporting at a venomous snake
and so when he woke up he realized what
happened and his health was
deteriorating all that's when he got
really emotional and he told his wife
that he wanted them to be together even
in the afterlife but he could well just
die with me God wanted them to die
together so he bit her wrist which she
let him and and then the couple fell
unconscious
now I award been the girl too well she
probably fainted from the pain being
reported that they were then transported
to a hospital which is the first thing
that should have happened in the
hospital the doctors are saying that it
was looked like luckily she was in time
they would have died the man ended up
dying oh no please please stay with me
honey that's so sad but it's so crazy
oh man dude I definitely want to die
before my wife goes why I want to watch
her die I can't you'll have to see it I
know there's too hard to spend that much
like years with somebody and then I
would be very it would be very hard on
think I'd be able to remarry I think I
figured out honest about bring it back
about myself I'm too emotional I can't
remarry yeah I took a pee all the time
like so when I die he's like why do you
always think we're going to icebergs I'm
like because you can't die before me
yeah
like if I see Muriel like slowly
deteriorating that's funny is better and
then you're gone oh yeah yeah have it
you're like god damn Oh [ __ ] down
Congress yep
oh no you're done I'm gonna die first
yeah no how about you guys what do you
think I think I have the stronger heart
so she bought I need to die first that
she needs to die but then we're asking
which one do you prefer do you want a
diverse did you well of course not like
to die first this but I did my heart
stronger than hers she could he could he
could survive it I could take it I don't
know she could take it like if I go out
swimming for like an hour that's love
you already can't take it that's true I
know God only the water top of it I
heard us specifically that in a couple
like if the female dies first the male
dies shortly after but if the male dies
first the females like tend to live a
lot longer because they're [ __ ]
heartless no because women the more we
evolve the less women need men I keep
saying so crazy because men are done
evolving because we're so tight and
you're still evolving stupid I've never
heard a keyboard open it yeah right
there at the top already baby you know
why guys die because they're so used to
their wives doing everything that now
they're stressed out because they're
like how do I [ __ ] pay this bill like
what the [ __ ] is going on and like or
where does this go like I don't even
know and then they're confused every day
that's why at the age involving they
look at a shirt like that's the highest
we've achieved I know look at that done
this means what the hapa I like to play
video game where went terribly wrong
against what you're saying hey at the
age of 55 would you be able to remarry
uh you're wrong dude yeah this u5 is
still pretty maybe five is not like 83
and I participant hypoxic Facebook I
can't do it I need
no I can't say I'm definitely halfway it
has nothing to do with the fact that I
don't have the life force left in me to
start you know young
it's just that let's say I'm pretty sure
by the time 55 I have a kid and somebody
the skalman thing about my wife you know
yeah that that person I've spent now up
to this point about 20 30 years together
I can't I can't have another experience
with this person that will ever match
that experience because he's gonna Bay
huggers think no I'm just gonna just be
alone and I'll be with my kids in my in
my pop pass like my mom is still like
super morning and like how she speaks
about it I'm just like oh yeah I can
imagine not not wanting to ever marry
anyone ever again cuz I feel like
because like what you said you spent so
many years with this one person yeah I
don't know what I can I'm almost a
hundred percent sure I will not be able
to do it I'll be like man I don't think
I can argue with another person like
that yeah but do you even have the life
force again just talked at all I don't I
don't know if it happens like that again
though you know argue this day me used
to argue in high school you know any is
anger is still the same it feels bad and
you have to relearn everything with this
person I just don't want to do and they
have to deal with their family and their
kids and their grandkids like you know
what I mean like it yeah like I think
that 55 to like hopefully I'm pretty
well-off at that point like I'm retired
I ought to be jet skiing like the whole
rich guy traveling living experiences
having a picture of my dead wife next to
me is showing her the rest of the world
like a but you will read
I could look like a crazy my dad date
and I think when you're at die age
you're really up front so as soon as my
dad hears like one thing that he doesn't
like he just like done you know I think
like when we're at our age or even
younger when you're dating with people
you can often like overlook that or like
oh that can be adjusted but then I think
by the time you get to that age they're
[ __ ] yeah there's no more [ __ ]
doesn't give a [ __ ] so he just dates and
he's like all that [ __ ] that this done
or that they said that I'm going to talk
about her and you're pretty upfront
anything the people I end up if you do
end up dating though that you would like
at that age you guys actually probably
do Matt
i something about my Grandmama's because
she passed away like six years ago I
don't think I'll be able to do something
like that right kids with this woman I
look at my kids face every day but all
[ __ ] that's not [ __ ] good wife you
know and I got but acknowledge that
their wife yeah this whole time I was
thinking divorce for some not divorce
like she's dead so that's like there's
no closure in that you're not happy and
then she just passes yeah I said like
something she did wrong
yeah you're happy 4:23 you still so
loved and then I'll know what happened
um they got be able to do that unless
I'm somebody who needs I don't think I'm
somebody who needs a physical person
there all the time I know like people
who have done that their whole life
they've been so used to having a woman
by their side that they need that no
matter who it is so but then there's me
where I was single and I was very very
very very happy
get up so if I happen to be single again
I think I'd be okay
any can't be with robbery married he's a
bit like that kind of guy where he's
always in a relationship always in a
shoe for the longest time that I've
known him is like more in a relationship
than not in a relationship
yeah you're probably really really just
don't die dude come on no I can't Axl I
know when you're 99 and [ __ ] that
[ __ ] gonna throw remarry watch out
hopefully by then our lifespan is our
life expectancy wings I think so I think
we're all going to the top 100 I think I
not the way my life is going I'm gonna
prove you wrong in the face 76 hope you
guys enjoyed that video but if you
didn't guess what you can directly
contribute to the article that we
discussed just cruise out over to the
description box below click on that link
to submit your article also for the next
video let's wrap up high